imagination rules the world
[Music]
the truest wisdom is a resolute
determination
ability is of little account without
opportunity
nothing is more difficult and therefore
more precious than to be able to decide
[Music]
a society without religion is like a
vessel without compass
the human race is governed by its
imagination
he who fear is being conquered is sure
of
defeat courage is like love it must have
hope for nourishment
[Music]
let france have good mothers and she
will have good sons
[Music]
a true man hates no one
[Music]
there is no such thing as accident it is
fate misnamed
[Music]
it requires more courage to suffer than
to die
never interrupt your enemy when he is
making a mistake
[Music]
soldiers generally win battles generals
get credit for them
men take only their needs into
consideration never their abilities
[Music]
take time to deliberate but when the
time for action has arrived stop
thinking and go
[Music]
death is nothing but to live defeated
and glorious is to die daily
you become strong by defying defeat and
by turning loss and failure into success
victory is not always winning the battle
dot but rising every time you fall
courage isn't having the strength to go
on it is going on when you don't have
strength
[Music]
the only way to lead people is to show
them a future a leader is a dealer in
hope
the purpose of religion is to keep the
poor from killing the rich
[Music]
envy is a declaration of inferiority
six hours sleep for a man 7 for woman
and 8 for a fool
the best way to make everyone poor is to
insist on equality of wealth
until you spread your wings you'll have
no idea how far you can fly
it is not necessary to bury the truth it
is sufficient merely to delay it until
nobody cares
the amateurs discuss tactics the
professionals discuss logistics
the world is not ruined by the
wickedness of the wicked but by the
weakness of the good
better to have an open enemy than hidden
friends
[Music]
a man will fight harder for his
interests than for his rights
friends must always be treated as if one
day they might be enemies
the fool has one great advantage over a
man of sense he is always satisfied with
himself
[Music]
i see only my objective the obstacles
must give way
once you have made up your mind stick to
it there is no longer any if or but
history is written by the winners
[Music]
the best way to keep one's word is not
to give it
the stupid speak of the past the wise of
the present and fools of the future
you become strong by defying defeat and
by turning loss into gain and failure to
success
[Music]
show me a family of readers and i will
show you the people who move the world
[Music]
a woman laughing is a woman conquered
history is a set of lies agreed upon
if i were to give liberty to the press
my power could not last three days
[Music]
victory belongs to the most persevering
half of the people in the world are
below average
[Music]
never ascribe to malice that which is
adequately explained by stupidity
the best cure for the body is a quiet
mind
the surest way to remain poor is to be
an honest man
[Music]
i base my calculation on the expectation
that luck will be against me
to have a right estimate of a man's
character we must see him in misfortune
after making a mistake or suffering a
misfortune the man of genius always gets
back on his feet
the reason most people fail instead of
succeeding is they trade what they want
most for what they want at the moment
[Music]
if you wish to be a success in the world
promise everything deliver nothing
impossible is the word found only in a
fool's dictionary
wise people create opportunities for
themselves and make everything possible
i am sometimes a fox and sometimes a
lion the whole secret of government lies
in knowing when to be the one or the
other
when a girl says no it sometimes means
keep trying
terrorism war and bankruptcy are caused
by the privatization of money issued as
a debt and compounded by interest
[Music]
don't marry the one you love but marry
the one who loves you
[Music]
the world suffers a lot not because the
violence are bad people but because of
the silence of the good people
[Music]
i am surrounded by priests who repeat
incessantly that their kingdom is not of
this world and yet they lay their hands
on everything they can get
there is only one thing in this world
and that is to keep acquiring money and
more money power and more power
all the rest is meaningless
[Music]
you